oh boy i need an uplift today and it is
time for an uplift at eight where we
share stories that will bring you some
joy new smile lines to your day vlad
what do you got this morning this is the
best thing you're gonna hear all day
okay story of a little girl who's
attending school for the very first time
in her life and she's exceeding every
expectation her name is mujna rasuli and
her family escaped from afghanistan last
year and moved to north carolina the
seven-year-old started first grade
knowing little english or anything about
life in the united states now she's
being recognized as a standout student
and wowing her teachers and her parents
take a look
the first few days where she was in our
classroom she
didn't understand anything that we were
saying and it was very overwhelming for
her but the last two or three months she
is speaking in sentences to us now the
transition that she's gone through and
everything that she's experienced you
wouldn't know we are happy my daughter
reached out this
achievement very proud of her i hope for
my family a bright future
a bright future especially for my
daughters
muchas father johnny there was an
interpreter for the united states army
he got out with his wife and three
daughters before afghanistan fell to the
taliban when musha's principal heard
about the family she rallied the
charlotte community to help them settle
in so a big big huge shout out to ray
view elementary yeah and way to go
moosha the future is right that's right
love it that was awesome that was a good
one told you